Okay.
Welcome to our session on the pathobiology of sarcomas.
I wanted to remind you a couple things.
We're going to have a webinar that will be sort of covering our
session, so all the questions should be made in the microphones.
That will be important. We're going to try to allow as much time for questions
as we can. The presentations will be 20 minutes, followed by 10 minutes of
questions, and we'll try, obviously, to give you
an opportunity. Of course, after the session, feel free to talk to any of
the speakers. I'm very excited about this.
We have a good program for you guys, and
we feel like it's a good moment to review some of the
technologies that are coming aboard and how we think about sarcomas,
hopefully increasingly in more systematic ways.
And we'll try to cover the idea of going from bench to bedside, using
some new molecular biology approaches to look at chromatin in sarcomas,
and also monitoring disease. So without further ado, our first
speaker is Brian Rubin from the Cleveland Clinic, and
he will be talking about bench to bedside in EHE.
Okay. Thanks very much, Miguel,
and thanks for organizing this, and thanks to all of you for finding this room.
I know that was probably a little bit of a trick. So, yeah.
I'm a pathologist. I'm going to talk a little bit
about just a really brief introduction to where we are with sarcoma
in terms of diagnosis and how I think genetics has really been
the game changer for us. It's been unbelievable the amount of genetic information,
and I'll show you a very dramatic slide kind of summarizing that in a moment.
But I work on something called epithelioid hemangioendothelioma, which is a rare
vascular tumor, and we'll talk about that largely.
So, I got a few slides from-- These are the slides from a talk I used
to give to residents about 30 years ago when I first started in this field.
And
we've traditionally classified sarcomas by their line of differentiation.
So if they're osteosarcomas, they make some sort of bony matrix.
Chondrosarcoma makes cartilage, et cetera.
Some of the things that we work on in sarcoma, like synovial sarcoma, Ewing
sarcoma, we still don't really understand the line of differentiation or the
cell of origin, or much about it, and that has to do with we've really kind of
lagged in the understanding of mesenchymal stem cell biology.
As it catches up, I think we'll learn more, and it'll be really insightful in our
understanding of sarcomas.
I always show this slide. So this was a slice through a patient's leg,
actually from an amputation specimen.
And really the extremities are the major sites, extremities and chest wall for
sarcoma development. You can see with all the different things, skin,
fat, bone,
et cetera. All the precursors, presumably, to give rise to these
cancers are living in the extremities, and that's why they're so common there, but
I just show it there dramatically.
And again, synovial sarcoma and Ewing sarcoma are unusual because they can
arise anywhere in the body, probably presumably from some sort of
primitive circulating stem cells that aren't located, for instance, in a
leg or wherever. And the way that we
traditionally classified when I was coming up as a resident, we used histology.
So we looked through microscopes, much as Virchow did for over 100
years, and tried to get a pretty good idea of what we're looking at.
Ultrastructure was pretty big back when I trained back in the '90s.
The Ultrastructural Pathology Society used to be a huge meeting at the
USCAP. Nowadays, you go and it's just a bunch of renal
pathologists. So ultrastructure has largely disappeared from the role
of diagnosing sarcoma. And then immunohistochemical studies
came up, and so we were using a lot of immunohistochemistry.
Now genetics. So, I trained back and I started my training in
'95.
We had translocations
that we were looking at, and there was a variety of translocations that were
specific for a variety of cancers.
And you can see here, this is kind of what we had at the time being.
Here's some of the translocations of something like extraskeletal myxoid
chondrosarcoma we knew was a 9;22 translocation.
So,
the cytogenetics has played a very key role in sort
of early understanding. We knew for things like
dermatofibrosarcoma protuberans, they had ring chromosomes composed of chromosomes
17 and 22, but this was really the extent of
our knowledge.
So now this is circa 2024,
and this is what we know about the genetics of sarcoma.
And so all these gene fusions have been cloned. I cloned a couple of them.
I was
lucky enough to clone a couple in my career and identify their genetic
alterations. But you can see there's mostly
gene fusions that are involving transcription factors.
There's some kinases, there's epigenetic regulators.
So we're really seeing the complete kind of picture here, and this is really due to
developments in things like
NGS, the Archer gene fusion panel.
I don't know if people know about that, but it's a way essentially of
PCRing using NGS
in a multiplex way, a variety of primers.
And John Ifrady's sitting here in the audience, who's really the guy who
created the tech behind the Archer gene fusion panel,
and we're still every week discovering a new gene fusion in my
group. We don't know what they mean most of the time, and we're going to move to
RNA-seq probably in the near future, and that will even just bombard us with
further information. But at this point,
this is what we're dealing with. It's a lot of genetic complexity, but it has
taught us a lot about classification of sarcoma, and
that's allowed us to feed information to oncologists to help
them treat and whatnot. And actually, we learned a lot about the biology.
So just to impress upon you, for me, the big game changer has just been
NGS and all of what we've learned from the variations of using
NGS.
So now I'm going to move on and talk a bit about EHE.
So,
epithelioid hemangioendothelioma is the full name.
For obvious reasons, I'm not going to keep saying
that.It's an ultra-rare sarcoma, so it actually
falls into the ultra-rare group. There's about 200 new cases in the United States
each year. There's
about 1,000 patients at any one time that have it in the United States because
they can live for a while. So we've got a wide age range with a peak in
middle age. It does occur in kids.
Arises in skin, soft tissue, bone, visceral organs.
And there are no standard treatment options for this disease, as there are for
many sarcomas. So on that last panel, we saw most of those
are chimeric transcription factors, and we just really haven't
figured out a good way to have a game plan now to
impact a chimeric transcription factor. Those targets are very obvious.
Treating them is an entirely different story.
The five-year disease-specific mortality depends on the location.
Soft tissue has the best prognosis.
Lung has the worst prognosis, especially pleural disease.
Once EHE involves the pleura or
the peritoneal surfaces, the patients have about a six-month survival time,
median of six months.
So this was built sort of as a pathology section.
So I did bring a few slides. I'll explain them to you if you're not a pathologist,
and I know that probably some of you aren't.
This is actually a liver with EHE in it, and it has a way of being vasocentric.
That's a blood vessel in the middle, and you can see it's stuffed with EHE.
Over on the right, here's what they look like.
And so what you can see here is
that there's a monotonous proliferation of these small cells.
They don't look very angry or outwardly malignant, and they're
set in this really abundant myxofibrillary kind of
stroma. Our lab actually spends a lot of time studying that
stroma, but I'm not going to talk about that today.
Now, they do stain for vascular markers, so here's CD31, which is a very good
endothelial marker, and then ERG on this side, which is also a good
endothelial marker.
Now, I got really interested in this disease because it had a translocation, and I
kind of liked cloning translocations.
And so this is a 1;3 translocation.
It involves the short arm of 1 and the long arm of chromosome 3.
And we didn't know what that was, but back in 2011, inspired by the work of
Arul Chinnaiyan, who was at that time using RNA-seq to just
sequence tumors, and then he would use bioinformatics to clone them out.
We were the first guys who said, "Well, we've got a translocation, so we know where
the fusion is." We just sequenced one tumor, and we got
the fusion in about a week. We'd actually been working on it for about two years at
that point using FISH walking and FISH mapping and shortcutted the whole process
using NGS. So it has this thing called a TAZ CAMTA1 fusion.
I'll talk a little bit about TAZ, but essentially TAZ CAMTA1 is a dysregulated form
of TAZ.
And over on the right side here, we just have some protein structures.
And really for the purposes of this talk, what's really important is that the TID
binding site of TAZ
is fused essentially to most of CAMTA1, but it retains that
TID binding site. That's a very critical interaction that
strategically everybody that's interested in drugging this
compound, either TAZ, YAP, or TAZ CAMTA1, is
trying to interfere with the interaction between TID and TAZ
or YAP.
Now, one of the things that's kind of interesting that's like a translation of
genetics now is we have what we call...
This is a term coined by my friend Jason Hornick.
He calls them next generation antibodies.
So here what we've got is a case of EHE on the left, and on the right
is a CAMTA1 antibody. CAMTA1 really isn't expressed at all in adult
tissues. A little bit in neuronal tissues, but really it's not expressed very
well. And so in any kind of cancer, if it stains for
CAMTA1, it is syniquannon for having the gene fusion.
And so we use CAMTA1 immunohistochemistry quite a bit to identify cases of
EHE
when we see them, and it has a nuclear stain, a little bit of cytoplasmic blushing
as well.
So here's the Hippo pathway. So the reason I'm talking about the Hippo pathway, now
I hope I'm not jerking around too much.
I'm trying to pile actually quite a few little stories into this
talk, is
that TAZ is the end effector of the Hippo pathway. So is YAP.
So down here we have TAZ, which lives in the cytoplasm and then migrates into the
nucleus where it acts as a transcription factor.
It's a transcriptional co-regulator.
It has to bind TID, and it's controlled by cell size
and cell shape. Those are the inputs.
They modify these serine/threonine kinases here, MST1/2 and
LATS1/2. LATS will phosphorylate TAZ.
If it's phosphorylated, it keeps it in the cytoplasm.
It's a tumor-suppressive pathway.
However, if it's unphosphorylated, it allows it to go into the nucleus where it
binds TID, and then it has a transcriptional program, which is very
pro-oncogenic.
So that interaction between TAZ and TID, I will emphasize again, is kind of
important. So when we cloned the gene fusion, there were no models.
I work in rare cancers. There's never any models.
We have to develop everything ourself.
All the models, tools, are all developed by the few people who actually study these
things. And so what we did was we expressed the gene fusion in
NIH3T3 cells. They grew as colonies in soft agar, which gave us
an assay, essentially, to start interrogating.
The first thing that we looked at, because we wanted to target TAZ CAMTA1, but of
course, that's easier said than done.
It takes a whole chemical program, and I'll show you a little bit about how we're
approaching that during this talk.
But essentially, we just looked to see what signal transduction pathways were being
activated. And what we found was that the MAP kinase pathway was
being activated more than the
PI3 kinase pathway. And you can see that here.
GDC-0941 is an inhibitor of PI3K, and it really doesn't
inhibit colony formation very well.
But PD325901 is a tool compound for the MAP
kinase pathway. It's a MEK inhibitor, and it has a dramatic
effect. It actually has an IC50 below 100 nanomolars.
Believe it or not, based on this data, almost exclusively, we did a clinical
trial in this disease.
Let me show you one more slide first.
So again, you can see we actually looked at trametinib, which
is-A compound out there that
was available clinically for melanoma.
And
so you can see that trametinib actually has a IC50 below 10
nanomolar, so it stops these colony formations.
So based on this data, we went into a clinical trial.
That clinical trial was led by a very good friend of mine, Scott Szucie
at University of Michigan.
It was NCI.0015, and also known as SARC-33.
It was a non-randomized, open-label, Phase 2 study of trametinib in
patients with unresectable or metastatic EHE.
Now,
I'll just cut to the chase. We actually published the data.
It's published in Clinical Cancer Research.
We didn't meet our endpoint,
but you can see here from this waterfall plot,
essentially these are the non-responders here.
We had four non-responders, but about 20 patients actually responded really well.
The drug's relatively toxic, so one of the things was we had to take patients off
because of the toxicity of the drug. But we actually had a great response.
Didn't meet our endpoint, though.
Didn't get FDA approved for this indication, but it really gave us an idea that we
were on the right track, let me say.
So, subsequently to doing all this sort of work with NIH3T3 cells, in
the background, we made a genetically engineered mouse.
This is the schemata of how we do it.
Essentially what we did was we put in a germline allele that we could
conditionally activate once the mice had gone through birth and were
living, to alter it to express TAZ
CAMTA1. So we converted, essentially, the native TAZ allele to a TAZ
CAMTA1 allele. All the mice that had the TAZ
CAMTA1 allele, and took two alleles, actually.
The heterozygous TAZ CAMTA1 mice did not get EHE.
All the homozygous mice did, and the tumors look identical to
human EHE at any level that you looked at them.
So they looked at them under the microscope, they looked right.
If you did immunohistochemistry, they're a vascular tumor.
If you did
RNAseq, they would have the same expression profile.
So every time we test these tumors, they are identical to human EHE.
Then one trick we did, so CDK2A is lost in human EHE about
half the time, and it's associated with aggressive behavior.
We didn't get cell lines. We couldn't grow cell lines out of the original mouse
model, so what we did was we crossed it into a CDK2A conditional background
to make mice that were TAZ CAMTA1 homozygous,
CDK2A homozygous. And then when we deleted
CDK2A, activated TAZ CAMTA1, we got aggressive tumors.
But nicely, those tumors were able to grow into cell lines.
And we've actually replicated this now using RB1 and some other tumor
suppressors. And you get the same effect each time.
The tumors are more aggressive, and you can make cell lines.
So we have this little library now of EHE mouse cell lines that we've made
with sort of different genetic backgrounds.
So we used those cells then to look to see, does trametinib inhibit them?
And of course they do, and you can see here.
Here's three different cell lines, 36, 317, and 3.26.
They're all inhibited. They have nice IC50s.
And then what we were interested in then was, could we combine that with TEAD?
And so there is a tool compound out there called MGH CP1,
made by Dr. Wu at Mass General. And
so TEAD inhibitors also work quite nicely. Now this is a tool compound.
It's active at millimolar concentrations, and so not something that's going to move
into the clinic. However, it does inhibit the growth of these
EHE cell lines,
and it also inhibits
a reporter construct as well.
And so then when you actually combine mechanists now with
trametinib, with
this TEAD inhibitor, you can see it has a synergistic effect as sort of
indicated here with this big hump in this plot here on
the right side. And so, these two synergize together, and we
imagine that TEAD inhibitors will eventually need to be combined with a bunch of
other and different kinds of inhibitors to move into the clinic.
Okay, so what else have we done? So once we got these cell lines, another thing we
did was we developed an assay to screen drug libraries.
And what we're interested in doing is looking for abrogation, essentially, of
TC expression, or removal from the nucleus, causing it to
be obliterated or whatever. And so you can see here, this is the way we set up
the assay. Here's TC in our cell line. Here's a blocking peptide.
We did the same thing with YAP and CAMTA1.
So we had different markers that we could use in this screen, and we set up a
384-well plate. We first looked at a bunch of inhibitors that
were thought to inhibit the Hippo pathway.
I didn't get into this, but Hippo pathway tries to
regulate the localization of TAZ CAMTA1, but it is unable to do so.
So TAZ CAMTA1 lives constitutively in the nucleus in
EHE, and in fact, none of these compounds worked.
Osmotic stress is the only thing that had any effect.
Sodium chloride at 200 millimolar, which essentially just blows the cells up
to a large degree.
Now looking at our screen, we started with these custom libraries that we have in
our medicinal chemistry group. We had about 4,000 compounds.
Just looking at things that had an increased cytoplasmic-to-nuclear ratio or
disappearance, essentially, of the nuclear signal, we had 38 hits.
Seven of them were active at one micromolar, and then we had clear dose responses
in five compounds. The five compounds are listed over here on the right.
So we have dinaciclib and CGP, which are both cyclin-dependent
kinase inhibitors. We have DBET6, which is a
bromodomain-containing protein, and a lot of people are interested
in BRD4 inhibition.
And then XPB.
Here's just a couple dose response curves looking at CGP.
So you can see it has a nice dose response curve, the same with dinaciclib, another
CDK inhibitor.
We did get at apoptosis with these compounds, and so,
again,
looking at CGP and dina, they both increased apoptosis to quite a
degree, which kind of surprised us, because usually these single inhibitors don't
do that.
Sorry.We did an in vivo study here.
So we're looking at, this is a xenograft mouse.
So our cell lines that we've created out of our genetically engineered model also
grow as xenografts. We can inject them into the flanks of these mice.
Here's actually
vascular invasion. There's a little clump of tumor traveling off.
And so these
cell lines actually metastasize at very high rates, which is kind of unusual.
Here you can see the lung of an untreated mouse, virtually completely replaced by
cancer. And then over on the right side, you can see after dinacyclin treatment.
So there was actually a really big
reduction in the amount of tumor
mass essentially in these lungs.
We looked to see which CDK's inhibitors
work, because a lot of these inhibitors inhibit more than one CDK.
And so it turned out dinacyclin inhibited this group over here
of cell cycle regulated and transcriptional.
And it turned out essentially, I'll just summarize, that CDK9 appears
to be the target of this.
And then our
current hypothesis is that a lot of the
compounds that were actually successful, so these ones over here on the left, all
turn out to target things that are part of this productive elongation complex.
It's involved in transcription. And so we think somehow that CDK9
inhibition blows apart the complex, and we have some data that
supports that now, and we're trying to develop that as a full story, but that
hasn't been published. This particular data's unpublished at this point, although
we published a lot of the CDK9 story a couple years ago in Clinical
Cancer Research.
And then I just want to talk about the last thing that we're really working on in
the lab right now, which is
we're trying to actually identify or develop an inhibitor
of TEAD, and we have an NCI Next program that I work
with a bunch of medicinal chemists, namely Sean Stauffer and Bin Zhou, who are
at the Cleveland Clinic. And so this is the structure actually of TEAD, and it's
got this central binding pocket, and then it's got these
external interfaces that are all drugable.
And so here's interface one, two, and three.
We are interested in drugging
interface three. These are where Yap and Taz would bind.
Here you can see actually dramatically, Yap, Taz, and something called Vestigial 2,
they all bind to these interfaces over here.
You've got Vestigial 1, 3, and 4 over here, and then PHAM proteins.
They all bind to different parts of TEAD, whether they're co-activators,
co-repressors, or unknown regulator function.
And so the idea here is to develop molecules.
So these are actually the binding sites for Yap and Taz, one of the
interfaces. And you can see that these pockets are occupied by different
parts of Yap and Taz.
Here's Yap over here and here's Vestigial 2.
And so the idea is to develop an inhibitor, a small molecule which sits in these
pockets and inhibits the binding.
And the way that we started doing this was, well, we tried a few
approaches, but the thing that worked the best was NMR peptide screening.
So you can get peptide libraries and then screen by NMR with the
interaction of these peptides with the
protein that you're studying. Here's the device that we use, and I
don't know much about that, so I'm not going to talk about it.
But
this would be the pipeline for how you develop this.
So the first thing is you get hits, then you do structure-based design, which is
where we still are largely in our study.
And I'm not going to talk a ton about it, but just a little bit.
But this is kind of what the data looks like.
For those of you who aren't used to looking at NMR data, probably one of the
funnest things I've done in my career is to hook up with these chemists a few years
ago and learn a lot of chemistry that kind of remembered a little bit from being an
undergrad. But essentially what happens is you can take something like TEAD, which
you're labeling now with 15N or other radioactive
compounds. You put a fragment in that may or may not bind it, and then what
you do is you look for shifts in this NMR spectrum.
So where you get a shift, and that's kind of shown up here going from red all the
way over to blue, that means that there's binding and there's binding affinity.
You can measure those affinities, believe it or not.
Here's what TEAD looks like binding to Vestigial 1, which is a known binder, and
you can see a lot of blue here. And so that means that the peaks have kind of
spread apart, and it's a good signal, and that would indicate strong
binding. And here's what a few just peaks would look
like. So here's a transition from this
pure red over here to blue. Here's red to blue, and this is a peak that's really
not
affected that much.
And so we looked at 1,920 compounds originally,
through these deconvolution steps. We got down to 37 hits.
We've been working on this now for about three years.
And I'm just going to show you,
there's too much IP around to show a lot of the data right now, I'm so sorry about
that, because we started off, this particular peptide
occupied P1 and P2 only,
and its affinity was about 10 micromolar.
We're now down to about 500 nanomolar with our study, with our medicinal
chemistry. So we've grown.
I'm not sure if it was this peptide in particular, but we've grown our peptide
now to occupy five pockets. We're getting down into the
activity that we need. We still need about another log, but I'm
excited that we've gotten this far with the project.
And by the way, there's a bunch of TEAD posters at this meeting.
People are really looking at TEAD degraders pretty heavily, but it's a really
interesting area that, and again, it's too short of a talk to talk that much
about. But just in summary, what we talked about here is that EHE
is driven by TAZ-CAMTA1 gene fusion.
It's really an example of a TAZ-addicted cancer.
TAZ-CAMTA1 is just really a dysregulated form of TAZ.
We recently developed these EHE GEM models and cell lines to study it.
We did phenotypic screen,
a small molecule library to identify CDK inhibitors.
We did fragment screening now with NMR.
And just to remind everybody, I only talked about the role of TAZ and Yap in EHE,
but we think that TAZ and Yap
are ubiquitously involved in cancer.
They're probably involved in virtually every cancer that you may or may not
study.These are my laboratory who
worked on this, my collaborators, our funders.
I like to show this slide. Even though this is a rare cancer, we
started a foundation about 20 years ago... No, 15 years ago now.
And the foundation has grown. So there's a lot of patients that have this
disease that are in an indolent phase, that hasn't gone to an aggressive phase,
which would kill them yet. And, so we asked over the weekend one
year, I said, "Hey, can somebody send me a couple pictures of EHE patients?" And I
got this collage back
the following week. And, it shows all these patients
with EHE. So again, all the projects I do are very
translational. They're all about bringing drugs to people and impacting
disease. Here is a picture of where I get to work, the Cleveland
Clinic in Cleveland, Ohio. If you ever want to come visit, give me a
call. I'm happy to answer any questions. Thank you very much.
And go to the microphone if you have a question. Yeah, I see a hand up.
Can you come to the mic?
Hi,
nice talk. I was wondering what is the role of the
CAMTA portion of the fusion in this cancer type?
Yeah, we are too. It's interesting. It's about 90% of the protein.
There's very little known about CAMTA1.
If you looked it up, did a PubMed search, you find about 30 papers, mostly in the
Arabidopsis literature, where it looks like some sort of tumor suppressor
in a way. It mitigates drought tolerance.
It is indicated in neuronal tumors as possibly being a tumor suppressor, but
nobody's ever been able to really nail it down.
We've actually done a lot of the kind of typical experiments you'd imagine, like
trying to mutate key residues, trying to delete portions of it.
And you can't really touch it without critically affecting the function.
It typically doesn't even get expressed once you start messing with it.
And so we've had a really, really difficult time teasing out what the role of
CAMTA1 is. But my hypothesis has
always been that it's... So remember that Tas is regulated by
the Hippo pathway, so it's phosphorylated and degraded out in the
cytoplasm. We know that it's phosphorylated because we've done a lot of proteomic
studies and shows that lats will phosphorylate it.
It's phosphorylated in cell lines and whatnot.
But it still lives in the nucleus predominantly.
And so we think CAMTA1 being a tumor suppressor is the idea, would
just sort of drag it into the nucleus because if you think about it, a tumor
suppressor wants to live in the nucleus where it's doing its job.
So
we haven't proved it yet, but I think that's probably the major role.
Cool. Thank you so much.
Yeah. Thank you for your question.
Yeah, John.
Hey, Brian.
Do you understand the Trementin story?
What
is the mechanism by which the fusions must be turning on something at the cell
surface or some pathway that's turning on MEK?
Do you understand that?
So,
you're getting into Hippo cell surface regulation and is that turning it on?
No, I don't think it
sees regulation at all by the fusion.
I think CAMTA1, whatever it's doing when it's fused to CAMTA1 just drags it into
the nucleus constitutively because we've tried changing cell
states,
doing things to modify it, and it doesn't really have
any effect. So it's not regulatable in the way that wild-type Tas
is. That's the trick. It's fused to CAMTA1 to become this
constitutively activated form of Tas.
If you look at Tas and Yap, they are exquisitely regulated by cell
size and cell shape, so that only in situations where you would want
to grow are they turned on because you can see what happens
when Tas and Yap are not regulated.
And I didn't talk about it, but Yap is actually fused in several cancers as well.
They're never in common cancers, but there's a rare form of a
pendemoma, for instance, that has a Yap fusion. Thanks for your question, John.
Yes.
Hi. Has anybody ever used or examined an MDM2 inhibitor in
these-
Ever used what kind of inhibitor?
MDM2 antagonist.
MDM2?
Because your wild type P53 and you've got loss of CDK and two-
Yes. Not that I know of. There's actually very few clinical studies
in this disease. It's so rare. People have really put a
lot of their horses into TEAD inhibition,
which
has shown some effects. If you inhibit TEAD in this, and there have been a couple
companies that have had programs,
that have had that. They do affect the disease, but no, people haven't looked at
MDM2 inhibitors yet.
Thank you for your question.
Thank you. Nice presentation. I'm having one question.
You have shown CAMTA1 IHC staining for fusion.
So I'm just curious, like this CAMTA1 IHC
staining can be used for any types of fusion, like in rhabdo or
Ewing sarcoma as well, or it's particularly for this fusion present
in this
sarcoma?
Yeah. Thank you for that question.
So,
no. So that's why it's a very specific antibody for this disease.
So as far as I know, CAMTA1's not expressed in any other kind of cancer,
and we've looked really extensively to show that.
So that's why you can use it as a surrogate for the fusion.
Now, there are surrogates for EWSRFLI1.
You can use a FLI1 antibody. Unfortunately, the antibodies don't work that well,
but there's a variety of fusions now where we have an
antibody to the C-terminal portion,
which is frequently the one that's not normally expressed.
And so, yeah, there's a group of antibodies.
It's not unlimited. It's relatively limited, but they can be used in this fashion
when they're available. Yeah.
Before I ask the question, so YAP1 is the same as WWTR1, is that right?
So Tas is WWTR1.
Tas, yeah. That's what I-
Yes. And it's confusing. The gene is WWTR1, Tas is the
protein.
So how certain are you that Tas is the business end of the
fusion? And the reason why I ask that is, I've got a sort of vague memory
from 10 years ago when I inadvertently sequenced one of
these, and they've got this peculiar configuration from
memory that-The WT,
WTR1 or the gene goes into the first
exon of CAMTA1 into the first amino acid, into the first
base, and then it's quite an extraordinary little thing where it does, but you sort
of get one codon being fused from two genes.
And as you said, most of the protein comes from CAMTA1.
Yeah.
Are you completely confident that TAZ is the business end
of the fusion? It just seems quite extraordinary in terms of normally when
gene fusions are fashioned, what you have is you have a promoter giver, then you've
got a business end. And as a general rule, the bit that does the
business is the bigger partner, and the promoter giver is sort of the smaller
partner.
Yeah. It's weird, but it's true. I'm absolutely convinced.
So it's always exon two or three of TAZ fused to exon seven or exon
nine of CAMTA1.
Every version of the protein that we've looked at-- Now, there's a couple really
bizarre, rare examples. Actually, we published them out there if you want to see.
There's a couple weird variant fusions.
But generally speaking, absolutely.
So you're really just fusing the TEAD binding domain of TAZ
to everything else in CAMTA1, which is driving all the transcriptional
activity and whatnot. I think that the reason you
see this in endothelial cancers is TAZ is highly expressed in endothelial cancers,
so it's got a strong promoter, and it's widely expressed in probably endothelial
precursors, which again, we don't know that much about, and I've never dove
backwards to try to figure out where this lineage of this primitive cancer
is coming from.
So let me maybe then ask you another question. Sorry.
I find this so fascinating because I'm sure I've been teaching my students
this the other way around, and I need to go back and try to remember who I said
this to and teach them that that was wrong.
So when you started off looking at this,
at the gene fusion, did you start
in an unbiased way, or did you decide early on that it must be--
Did you entertain the possibility that maybe it could be CAMTA1
that's doing the business?
So we've made the constructs, which would ask that question very specifically in
NIH3T3 cells. So we tried to take the CAMTA1 TAZ
reverse, if you will. You know what I'm talking about?
So the other way around had no transformation activity at
all. You can mutate the TEAD binding site, for instance, in
TAZ CAMTA1, completely abrogates all activity.
I see.
And I don't have time to get into it.
We've published, I think, a large amount of papers in this area.
I think it's very conclusive.
Thank you.
But great question. And we did ask that. You know what? I'm so sorry, you guys.
I think we're going to have to move on, but I'm going to be around for a little bit
afterwards if people want to talk, and thank-- I see other people want to ask
questions, but I think I will yield to my colleague here.
Thank you all for the great questions.
So I would definitely encourage you to come and talk to the speakers at the end.
So,
I'm going to take a little bit of a different tack here and
concentrate on chromatin. And what I
wanted to start with is by telling you a little bit
of how I got into thinking about sarcomas, and I
had been studying chromatin for a while as an important
component of cellular differentiation and development.
And looking at the results, this is an early summary
by Mike Lawrence at MGH
in Gary Getz's group
of mutations in cancer. And it became really clear, I
think, early on that there are tumors like rhabdoid tumor, Ewing sarcoma, and many
sarcomas that are driven by one oncogene that
was very easy to identify, and it was surprisingly powerful.
And so for me, it was like, this is a great thing to study
because this one oncogene, first of all, very often involves a
transcriptional regulator or some transcription factor or some chromatin regulator,
and it's a single insult that is going to do the whole job of cancer from
initiation to progression, metastasis, et cetera.
And the beautiful thing from the technical point of view
is that in these tumors, because they had these stereotypical fusions and
a relatively quiet genome, you could apply chromatin profiling
technologies relatively easily without having to worry too much about copy number
changes and that. Right? So this,
by way of introduction, I'm going to focus on a set of tumors that
are very good starting places to think about chromatin
in sarcomas and chromatin in cancer.
But of course, there's many sarcomas that then we have to think about and try to
extrapolate these two, such as osteosarcoma, liposarcoma, where the genomes
are more complex, but where these technologies, I think, will also be very useful.
So the focus for our lab quickly became the
EWAS FLI1 fusion in Ewing sarcoma,
which I should remind you, is really part of a very large set of fusions.
Similar to what Brian just showed you, there's a lot of fusions in
sarcomas, and this is a very large family of them.
And it involves fusions between the FET proteins fused EWAS and
TIF15, and a number of transcription factors.
And the story very often is
driven by the genetics, and the genetics teaches you so much that sometimes in
retrospect, you start understanding what the genetics was telling you.
But if you look at this set of fusions, there's an important principle.
You always have the disordered domain of EWAS or one or
another FET protein attached to a transcription factor or a chromatin
regulator.
So we'll get back to this soon, but why is it that you have such a
stereotypical pattern for these fusions?
And not only that, this is an example from clinical data similar to what
Brian showed. We keep finding more EWAS fusions, not just the ones that we know
from Ewing sarcoma and other tumors, but we keep finding surprises.
So one of my favorite ones is a colon cancer case that had an EWAS
TCF7L2 fusion that we saw in the MGH clinic.
So this is a general principle, bringing this disordered domain, attaching it to a
transcription. Why is that? SoAs a chromatin
person in the epigenomic era
our first
goal was to map the fusion and look at its chromatin environment,
and luckily we had a lot of cell lines that we could do this with in Ewing
sarcoma. And when you look at the fusion in Ewing sarcoma, it is
usually located in an active chromatin environment, as
shown here by K27 acetyl. And
what we found and had been described earlier in the literature in
some instances of promoters, a lot of these active sites that have
EWS FLI1 binding actually have a repetitive DNA
recognition sequence, GGAA, GGAA.
And this is important because ETS factors like FLI1
recognize GGAA motifs, oftentimes with a spacer between
them, and they sort of make a dimeric kind of
arrangement in binding. But this is highly unusual to find repeats
and microsatellite repeats of GGAA.
And so this is something that became really interesting and very
apparently different about what we saw in Ewing sarcoma.
There was also another category of sites that I will not focus very much on,
but these are what we call repressive sites.
So these are the active sites and suffice to say that it was
very exciting when we actually knocked out the fusion and you actually have
a total loss of K27 acetyl activation marks.
So these are really activating sites.
There's some sites of EWS FLI1 where the fusion binds to non-repetitive sites
in the genome, and these actually tend not to be very active.
So the fusion actually, for some reason, is much better at activating
chromatin and microsatellite repeats and not very good at activating chromatin at
sites that do not have microsatellite repeats.
I will focus on the microsatellite repeats for the rest of the talk,
particularly because we went to
what was the early versions of ENCODE data at the time, working with Brad
Bernstein, and asked the question, are microsatellite repeats,
GGAA repeats, ever active in cancer?
And so we looked at a set of DNA's data at the
time and DNA sensitivity, and we only had
one cell line that showed open chromatin at
GGAA microsatellite repeats. And it turned out that this was a cell line that
was misannotated. It was actually a Ewing sarcoma cell line that
entered the ENCODE pipeline. And it had this
incredible signal here, but all the other ENCODE cell lines that had been
profiled didn't have any activity on microsatellite repeats.
And importantly, if you think about
this collection of cell lines, many of them have the wild-type FLI1
transcription factor expressed at very high levels.
There's many of the lineages that are represented have FLI1, and yet
they don't have the microsatellite repeat activation.
So this prompted a simple experiment, which was to
go into a mesenchymal stem cell model and introduce EWS FLI1
versus the wild-type FLI1 transcription factor.
And if you do this experiment, it's actually a very clear result.
EWS FLI1 binds microsatellite repeats,
whereas FLI1 does not or kind of tries to bind.
You have a little bit of signal here, but not really a stabilization of the
complex.
The fusion protein actually opens chromatin beautifully, FLI1
does not on these microsatellite repeats, and it activates chromatin beautifully on
microsatellite repeats, but FLI1 does not.
So for us, it's very exciting because you're talking about something that's
fundamentally different about the oncogenic version of a transcription
factor compared to the wild-type version of a transcription factor.
So looking at other EWS fusions, we have found the same theme.
So in clear cell sarcoma, EWS ATF1 and DSRCT, EWS
OT1 have similar patterns of unusual
transcription factor binding sites, often loosely repetitive, not necessarily
perfect microsatellites, where they like to bind and where
the corresponding wild-type transcription factor never goes.
So we think that one of the themes of these fusions is that they
are pioneer factors in different parts of the genome compared to the
wild-type transcription factor.
So what else do they do? I will quickly go through this. This is already published.
They make loops, of course. When these things bind, they form
enhancer-like structures that have this concentration of the fusion protein, and
they nicely loop. And in fact, they are dominant in terms of the looping structure
in the genome. This is from EWS FLI1.
The loops made by EWS FLI1 binding are enormous by Hi-C.
The loops here shown in blue are actually the loops that do not involve
EWS FLI1 in this cell. So it's a huge difference in terms of the ability
to change this 3D configuration of the
genome. And we felt that it was
important to prove that these strange binding sites, these
microsatellite repeats, were actually important for the disease because it could
have been an epiphenomenon. It could be a sticky protein and somehow you bind.
So the way that we answered this question was to create an
artificial zinc finger transcription factor that can only
bind GGAA repeats, and we did this in collaboration with Keith Joung's lab, who's
an expert in zinc fingers. We tried to do this experiment by CRISPR initially.
It doesn't work. It's actually very hard to have a CRISPR attach
specifically at microsatellite repeats because the protein is very
large, and the spacing is difficult, and in fact, it's very hard to have CRISPRs
bind thousands of sites in the genome.
If you make an artificial zinc finger, you can actually design it such
that it only binds microsatellite repeats.
So we can actually replicate the transcriptional signature of
Ewing sarcoma by adding an EWS zinc finger, which was our positive
control. We can do this, and it binds very nicely.
It doesn't bind to the single GGAA sites, only to the repetitive ones.
And in fact, it activates chromatin very well.
But most importantly, when we actually switch off the
activating part of the zinc finger to a Krab domain, repressive domain,
we actually can silence all the microsatellite repeats and not the GGAA binding
sites in the genome. So it's a very specific genetic trick that we're using.
We turn off all the microsatellite repeats, and lo and behold, what we see is that
Ewing sarcoma cell lines completely collapse, whereas other types
of cells are fine with this massive
silencing of the genome that we actually have induced.
But it's the Ewing sarcoma cells that are exquisitely sensitive to the
microsatellite activity.So,
why is all of this happening? Why is the transcription factor in this
oncogenic form being able to go to a different part of the genome?
So obviously the answer, now going back to genetics, was always about
EWS, right? So if you have the weird addition of a
disordered domain, there's always a disordered domain of a FET protein.
So a transcription factor, is that doing something new?
So it turns out that EWS and FET proteins have a different
life in science, in neurodegeneration, because they have been linked
to an abnormal aggregation in neurodegenerative diseases.
And there's a number of papers particularly linking fuse and now
TAF15 as well to the neurodegenerative diseases like ALS and others.
And in fact, there's been some really exciting papers
published that show that you can actually model
this pretty well in a number of different assays,
and this is an interesting picture from a paper
from the McKnight Lab in UT Southwestern, showing that
these things make gel-like globs of protein when you actually
can purify, which is really hard to purify, by the way,
but they also precipitate very quickly out of
solution. So we were able to show that many of these properties, and
actually not surprisingly, are maintained by the EWS-FLI1
version of this that contains this EWS disordered domain.
So we went back to our model system in mesenchymal stem cells, and
we can ask
the question now, what if we disrupt the disordered properties of
the EWS domain? And to do this, we just borrowed a number of mutants that have been
described in the neurodegeneration literature that abrogate the phase
transition properties of the disordered domain.
So we borrowed these mutants, which are not a single
amino acid mutant, but a series of amino acids that change a number of the
tyrosines in the disordered domain.
And when you make this and you lose the ability to
undergo phase transitions, you actually lose the activity of turning
on enhancers. So we actually need the activity for
turning on enhancers. But most importantly, we also made a number of
mutants that attached small pieces
of the EWS disordered domain to FLI1.
And these are non-contiguous small pieces of about 80 amino acids.
And you can get any of those pieces attached to FLI1, and you recapitulate the
ability of a fusion to turn on all the microsatellite
repeats and turn on all the genes that we're familiar with in Ewing sarcoma.
So really, we feel that this makes a very strong point that the
properties of the disordered domain of EWS are really responsible for this
ability to change the binding properties of
the transcription factor and bind to microsatellite repeats.
So now this is something that has
become an interesting area of biology.
I think one of the examples that brought this forth was the
work on EWS fusions
by our lab and others.
And let me just show you that
when you express
the IDR of a FET protein with an mCherry, you
actually form these condensates.
And condensates are a term that has become very prominent in the
literature. There's still some problems with the definition, but clearly, if you do
the experiment, you form these kind of lava lamp
like aggregates of protein. So these proteins
really like to come together. That might be an explanation for why
they are very good at binding microsatellites, because they stabilize the
proteins in those locations. But there's also an important point to be
made here. This is just the disordered domain by itself,
which eventually, once you start forming, with epigenetics you can stimulate
this, you start forming the condensates, they eventually just glob onto
each other and just become a single dot, right?
If you have attachment to the DNA, like what we
see in the
case of the tumors, and this is actually a construct made by Sacha Xiong
in Robert Tjian's lab, which actually has a Halo tag attached to the
fusion endogenously. What you see in this type
of assay is actually that these things don't stick to each
other. They just stay attached to the chromosome.
So the interaction with the DNA keeps the condensates from totally going
awry and actually keeps them in a functional configuration where they can still
activate the enhancers. So there's an interesting balance there that could be
something to think about in terms of how this system is maintained.
And importantly, Sacha was able to show very nicely that
the sites where we find microsatellites are actually surrounded by
clouds of deposition of EWS
and FET proteins that you can actually track on the
nucleosomes. So are these condensates, do they have all the properties
of condensates? That is actually very hard to do because condensates, as we
understand them, are often defined by
analogy or to
membrane-less organelles like the nucleolus.
So there's a number of properties that you can study at that scale.
These are enhancer size condensates.
They're really small, and some of the things that you would like to do in
terms of testing their properties actually stretch the limits of some of the
microscopy techniques.
So,
the model then is that once you have
a transcription factor that's fused to an EWS domain,
you have the ability to bind different parts of the genome, and that is going to
let you activate new sites. So for us, this
brought forth the disordered domain
as a really important aspect of the biology of these fusions that really needs to
be studied and that we need to understand better.So we saw, and this is
where some of the
amazing insights that come from studying rare diseases can guide
you into interesting parts of biology.
I think it has happened over and over
in molecular biology, for sure. And for us, it just made us
ask the question, can we look at how disordered domains arrange themselves in the
nucleus? So we came up with an idea that actually was based on an
experiment done by Steve McKnight,
which was using a chemical precipitant of disordered
proteins to try to map them in the genome.
So what the McKnight lab had done was found that there's a
chemical called beta-isox that has the ability to precipitate disordered
proteins. Why is that? It's because it creates microcrystals, and
those crystals then are able to interact with
polypeptide chains that are not globular.
A globular chain does not
interact with a microcrystal, but a chain that is loose will interact and
will precipitate. And this has been used in a number of biochemical
assays that we had used in terms of Western blotting or whatnot.
But we had the idea, well, if we're doing this, why don't we collect all the DNA
that comes down with the precipitates and map it back to the genome?
So if you do that in a technique that we call DiF-seq, we were surprised that
you get actually something that looks very much like ChIP-seq without any
antibodies. So you can actually look at where is there a big concentration of
disordered proteins in the genome.
And here's a peak right where Eos fly one is sitting.
You have this whole blob of disordered proteins that is sitting there, and
notice how much bigger it is than the binding site of the transcription factors.
There's a number of other things that are here.
Importantly, it's not just where the fusion is, is a Ewing sarcoma, but also there
are a number of places where there's no fusion and also there's
aggregations of disordered proteins that we have no idea what
they are. So we did some analysis of this, and of course, we
can find it in different parts of the genome, in activated places.
Interestingly, weak enhancers have actually more signals for disordered
proteins than active enhancers. So this doesn't match, for example,
with cadence and acetyl perfectly, doesn't match with, I would say, even
ATAC-seq exactly because we find places that are closed chromatin that have
disordered domains attached to them.
And in fact, this kind of analysis, the only analysis that will
show you that there are proteins, this is a large enhancer.
There's protein signals in places of enhancers that we wouldn't know belong to the
enhancer if we were looking at cadence and acetyl, and we wouldn't know if they're
part of bound sites if you look at ATAC-seq, but actually probably
form an interesting architecture that we're not aware of at this point.
So you can actually map what domains are binding to the sites, and we can find some
transcription factors that actually are represented in some of
the sites that we've identified. We can also
do experiments where we repeat this assay after turning off the Eos fly
one fusion, for example. And interestingly there, what we found is that we
see a big increase in signals after we turn off Eos fly one.
All the Eos fly one sites disappear, but there's a number of
sites that appear. So this brought us to an interesting
realization, which is that if you look at these very large DiF-seq domains,
very often you have other transcription factors, not just Eos fly one, that are
attached to these locations. Okay?
But when you actually turn off the fusion,
this whole complex and this whole very large size, this is about
five KBs in size. This whole thing just disappears,
and it releases a number of proteins with disordered domains that are sitting in
this location. One of them is a transcription factor that we were able to map,
NFIB, that then goes on and sits somewhere else in the genome.
So the fusion proteins are not only able to open new
parts of the genome and activate it, but also are attracting a lot of
disordered proteins and procreating a situation where you have
sequestration of disordered proteins in an abnormal way.
And a lot of these transcription factors that are sequestered are actually
important in terms of differentiation pathways.
So I won't go into all the details, but we can show that the attraction of
transcription factors such as NFIB is dependent on the IDR, and in fact, that
the IDR of NFIB alone is enough to
take the protein to the places where the condensates of abnormal Eos
proteins are located. So the interactions between IDRs are very
important, and we're only starting to understand how those work.
So we have a model where activation of enhancers is important,
and it's actually a unique
feature of the translocated transcription factors that is different from the other
transcription factors. But there's also sequestration of other disordered proteins.
And all of these components are probably contributing to
what this fusion protein is able to do. So how do we target this?
And I haven't focused on therapy in this
talk, but just to give you some thoughts, of course, now there's a
whole interest in these condensates and how people can
assess these and probably screen for abnormalities
and targeting of condensates. And there's a number of companies working in this
area that I think are doing interesting work.
Of course, also the loops and targets that we have defined are potentially
enriched for a number of important mediators of the biology of these diseases.
And interestingly, my colleague, Kim Stagmeier, who will be giving a talk later
in this meeting,
has shown using CRISPR screening that there's a number of synthetic
lethal relationships in Ewing sarcoma, for example.
Interestingly, a lot of these are related to the biology of the fusion
itself. Here I'm showing the example of Trim8, which actually turns out to be
controlling the levels of Eos fly one protein.
So these are all the folks involved in this work. I'll be happy to take questions.
There's so many transcription factor effusions
and whenever I look at a transcription factor it always has a
transactivation domain, just says TAD.
Right.
How many of those are disordered and is this
what you're showing a universal phenomenon in a lot of these
transactivation domain? I'm just thinking also of Brian's talk-
Yeah
...
where he has a bridging transcription factors, bridging TEAD to
the Camta transactivation domain.
Right.
Is Camta one doing this also from a disordered domains?
A lot of transcription factors have disordered domains and I think we've always
not focused on that that much but they seem to be playing an
important role. Some of the corollaries of the data on this seek that I showed
actually have been telling us that transcription
factors, we know this, there's way too many sites for a transcription factor to
bind in the genome and somehow it is choosing places
where to go. Right? And so that seems to actually not have to just
to do with the specificity of DNA binding domain but also the interactions
between transcription factors in a scale that is probably larger than what we
thought before and we think the IDRs contribute to that.
What happens in disease when you start swapping IDRs or you put in a
really powerful IDR you start changing the properties of the transcription factor.
Hi. Really cool talk. So I'm thinking specifically about the video that you
showed with the lava lamp analogy used and
just thinking about the efficiency of EWS-FLI it looks
like that might
force all of the EWS-FLI onto one microsat repeat
region and so I'm wondering if you have any ideas about how this process might be
regulated to prevent all of the EWS-FLI in the cell to go to
one spot.
Right.
And the repression targets and the other targets that-
Yeah. So to get the strong lava lamp moving
you do it without a DNA binding domain so that is an artificial
situation that really exaggerates the process but your point is well taken,
right? How you prevent these things from totally
accumulating in one place and we know they're very sticky because of all these huge
loops that we're seeing. Right? So I think that there's a regulation of
these processes at the level of chromatin probably by some protein
players that we don't know. We know RNA is involved to a certain extent in
regulating condensate behavior,
but there's a lot to be defined.
Does the condensate activity increase residence
time on chromatin? So could that possibly explain why
EWS-FLI prefers-
Yes
... activation to repression?
Yes. That is a very good point. Yes. We think it does.
We
don't have the resolution of
making that point precisely but we think that's probably what is happening.
Certainly in terms of stabilizing the interactions which are
very transient and I think the best clue is when you do
FLI1 by itself which has the edge binding domain you see a little bit. Right?
The scanning and sampling of the genome is happening but
the EWS-FLI1 stops there and makes the enhancer.
So to follow up on that so if you have a single GGAA
why does the IDR not
recruit in other EWS-FLIs?
When you have a single
GGAA not in a microsatellites?
You see condensation at the repressors, right?
Yeah. So
I oversimplified this a little bit.
When you have a single GAA there's a
range of behaviors. One of the things that we think
is that
it can induce, we actually see these six signals in places that don't have
microsatellite repeats. They're smaller but we actually can detect
that it does form some sort of complex.
The outcome of that interaction is highly dependent on what
is there. So for example if an X factor was sitting there that is
very highly active, effusion sometimes displaces that and actually is not as
active as that H factor. So the outcome is less easy to
track than the microsatellites. That's why we focus on the microsatellites a lot.
Great. Thank you.
All right.
Thanks everybody for staying for the end of the session and I'm really thankful
for the invitation to participate.
I am a clinician, take care of patients who have sarcoma, in particular GIST,
and I'm going to talk about GIST as a paradigm for personalized medicine and
sarcoma and also leverage a lot of our clinical
trial data to see how we've made progress in understanding the disease
as we're moving forward.
So for the basics, GIST is the most common GI sarcoma.
It's a rare tumor when you think about it as in all GI tumors but very common
in terms of GI sarcomas.
It is seen across the spectrum of ages but most commonly in patients between
40 to 60 years of age and slightly higher in men than women
and if you look worldwide the incidence is about 12 per million.
To the right you can see the
picture of where these tumors arise, really anywhere along the GI tract
but most commonly in the stomach followed by the small bowel.
Before we knew how to target this drug,
we really didn't have anything to take care of this disease and this is
progression-free survival, the time to which after starting a new drug
to the time of progression if you treated these patients with cytotoxic
chemotherapy and that was essentially the time that they had their first assessment
of response so it didn't work.
Surgery has been a very useful tool for caring for these patients
particularly in the first line setting but people who had
recurrent disease or in whom had metastatic
disease if you couldn't completely remove it their survival was quite
short at less than a year.What really
changed how we thought about this disease was this seminal paper by
Hirota and colleagues, who identified KIT mutations in
GIST.
They found that these mutations led to constitutive
activation of the downstream signaling, and in elegant studies in
knock-in mouse showed that these KIT mutations were
sufficient to induce GIST. And so this changed
how we thought about this disease.
Not only how we thought about it, but also how we diagnosed it.
To show some pathology slides,
the identification of KIT as a marker for this disease
allowed us to use CD117
to
identify these tumors.
And it is positive in the majority of cases, almost 95%.
For those that are not positive for CD117, we now use a marker called
DOG1. And really, these two
antibodies and markers allow us to
diagnose this tumor correctly. It's probably old
news now, but in the past, many of these tumors were called leiomyosarcomas, and
desmin is a marker for leiomyosarcoma.
So I always tell my trainees, if it says desmin positive, it's
not a GIST.
So over time, since the initial description by Mazur and
Clark in 1983, we've really come to identify or understand
many of the molecular drivers for this tumor.
And this is a timeline of what we've seen.
KIT exon 11 was the first site of a mutation in
KIT that was identified in 1998, but we've come to learn that there are more.
And along the way, PDGFR alpha, NF1,
SDH deficiency, BRAF, and NTRK are all
markers or molecular drivers for this tumor.
In this cartoon, which shows KIT and PDGFR alpha, they are
homologous
kinases that have similar structures as well as downstream signals.
And you can see that there are some hotspots for mutations that are
associated with this disease. Exon 11 for patients who have
KIT is the most common site of mutation, followed by exon nine.
And when we look at PDGFR alpha, it's actually slightly different.
It's down in exon 18. And you can see that these represent different
parts of the kinase structure. I'm going to introduce two
terms now,
the ATP binding pocket and activation loop, because these are common
sites for secondary mutations that I'm going to discuss in a moment.
So we've identified these mutations as
drivers, and we've come over the past 25
years, 26 years to have approval of a variety of tyrosine
kinases. The majority of these drugs are tyrosine kinases.
I did also include larotrectinib as the first NTRK inhibitor
that does have activity for those
rare GIST tumors that have NTRK fusions as their driver.
But really importantly for us as clinicians, it's really important to know what the
molecular driver is so that we can treat the patient correctly.
The first studies that were done in GIST with imatinib showed
very high activity, and so it led quickly to Phase III study that
was done both in the United States through SWOG, and it
included Canada, and then with the ORTC in Europe and
Australasia. And this study was a Phase III trial that
compared two different doses of imatinib,
and the data was combined with these two studies.
And what you can see here is that progression-free survival and overall
survival were quite good compared to what we were experiencing
before. The median survival for these patients looked to
be about five years, which is much different from that one year we spoke about
previously, but that the response in terms of how patients
did varied based on what their mutation was.
I will say that this data was collected in the early 2000s, and so our
ability to detect different mutations was more limited than it
is today, but KIT exon 11 mutations do the
best,
and KIT exon nine mutations overall tend to do the poorest with
the others in between.
So
this is a little bit out of sequence.
I should've
just introduced imatinib. It is the drug that
we use. It is developed
as a BCR-ABL inhibitor for CML, but did also have
activity for
patients with KIT and PDGFR alpha mutations and was
studied.
So when we look at resistance in that Phase III data,
where did we see resistance? Because not everybody responded, and this
was an important key into understanding the drug and what its activity could be.
So the patients with exon nine mutations did not respond as
well, as you can see by their outcomes.
Also, PDGFR alpha mutations did not respond as well
as wild type. I'm not going to talk about the wild type tumors
today, but let me go a little further in terms of the exon nine mutation
patients. As you can see on the
left, the PFS curves for the whole patient
population showed no significant difference between the
two different doses of the drugs that were used, 400 versus 400
twice a day. However, when you looked at the exon nine mutation patients,
there was a difference, and that these patients had improved
outcomes when they were on the higher dose.
And so this was the first way that we started doing really
increased personalized therapy for patients with exon nine mutations by
increasing their doses in patients who had advanced disease.
So to sum it up in terms of thinking about imatinib, it's a very effective
drug, which improved the survival of these patients from one to about five
years. But there were limitations, and those limitations were exon
nineSome PDGFR alpha mutant GIST, and then, as I said, the
non-KIT/non-PDGFR alpha mutant tumors.
So what do we do, and what do we know about PDGFR alpha mutant GIST?
So this is retrospective data from the French sarcoma
group that looked at their population, and they showed some interesting
things. These tumors were primarily arising in the stomach, although
previously I said it was about 55% from the stomach.
In the PDGFR alpha context, it's much higher. It's almost 70%.
These tumors were more likely to be KIT negative in their series,
up to 12%, and the majority of these patients had a
specific mutation, the D842V substitution.
What does that substitution mean?
Well, when they looked at their outcomes in terms of progression-free survival,
these patients fared much worse with
very limited response or benefit from therapies that they were
receiving. And specifically for the agents that were available at the time that
they were treated, imatinib and sunitinib, and others, they really had
almost like the chemotherapy, had progression in the time of their
first scan.
So,
what were we going to do? The standard therapies that we had that were available
really didn't affect or target the activation loop, and there was no
highly effective agent of any line until we tested
avapritinib. Avapritinib is a very selective kinome
agent, specifically targets the activation
loop in PDGFR alpha and also in KIT.
This was tested in vitro, and you can see compared to the dark blue of
imatinib, the light blue of
285 or avapritinib, it has a much lower IC50,
particularly for these activation loop mutations, including PDGFR
alpha D842V.
And in the phase I trial that was extended to have an expansion
cohort for these patients, you can see that none of the patients had
progression of disease, and the majority had their tumor decrease in
size, and some of them had complete response.
The overall response rate of the various drug levels was greater than
90%. There were no patients who had progressive disease, and that
response happened quite quickly at within two months.
In long-term follow-up, the patients have had ongoing benefit with
median progression-free survival of over two years, and the overall
survival not yet met at the time of the publication of this series.
So avapritinib is really very effective, particularly for D842V
GIST, and significantly improved those patients in terms of
survival in advanced disease.
One limitation of the agent, which is different from many of the other agents that
we use, is it does have some CNS penetration, and we do see some
toxicity in terms of memory and sometimes some
psychiatric issues that needs to be monitored,
and one of the reasons it's not used standardly sort of in the adjuvant
setting, the way we do with other agents for
GIST.
As a reminder, GIST can be very well treated
if it has a PDGFR alpha12 or 14 mutation with imatinib and other
standard kinases.
So I'm going to move on to tyrosine kinase resistance, and I think this is where
our clinical trials have really been helpful in terms of us understanding
resistance and how it's evolving based on selective clonal pressure.
This series of CT scans is one of a
patient who's had metastatic disease involving the liver.
And you can see here contrast-enhancing lesions, which on
treatment with imatinib, became
cystic-appearing or losing enhancement, but then
in the future, developed these nodules within a nodule.
And at the time of surgery, when these were resected and evaluated, there were
three different
secondary mutations in this one nodule.
So progression really became polyclonal.
I'm going to jump to sunitinib, which was the next drug that was tested, to
talk about what we've come to understand about resistance.
But sunitinib is a tyrosine kinase inhibitor.
It inhibits KIT, PDGFR alpha, VEGF, as well as
some other kinases, and was the second drug that was approved based on
this trial in which patients were
treated
with sunitinib versus placebo, and there was clearly a very striking difference in
terms of progression-free survival as well as overall survival.
In correlative data that was actually done in the phase I and phase II
studies, they studied
what was happening in terms of secondary mutations for patients who started on
sunitinib. What did the tumors these patients have, and what did their
secondary mutations look like? And we can see at the time that the patients
progressing on imatinib were very likely to have secondary
mutations in the ATP binding pocket, less likely to have it in
the kinase activation loop. And then one study to look at how did
response happen with this drug, with sunitinib, the
ATP binding pocket was quite well
inhibited and controlled as compared to those with the activation loop
mutations. Structurally, sunitinib can get into the
pocket,
where these mutations are, in a way that imatinib can't, and so it
can control this set of mutations.
So what do we do about these patients who have these AL mutations?
And so there was a series of discoveries looking for
AL inhibitors, particularly for exons 17 and 18,
and these patients are not treated well with sunitinib.
And so two drugs that were specifically developed to try and
control these areas was repretinib, which has a
novel mechanism as a KIT switch control inhibitor, and then
bevaclestinib, which is a type I KIT inhibitor.
So let me talk about repretinib first. In vitro, it looked like a great drug.
It really managed everything at very low
IC50s, including its secondary metabolism, compared to other
drugs that were available at that time.The INVICTUS
trial was the phase three trial that compared
repretinib to a placebo in the third or fourth-line setting.
These patients had had sunitinib as well as other drugs.
And you can see here now looking at secondary mutations
using tissue biopsies, but also liquid biopsies,
another way now that we have to be able to assess what are the arising
secondary mutations or resistance mutations.
And you see that there's been more of a shift towards the activating loop
mutations.
When looking at the benefit of repretinib, it seemed that it didn't matter where
the mutation was, at least in this evaluation.
And so this led to thinking about could repretinib be a
broader drug that could replace sunitinib in the second-line setting
because it could cover everything.
And so the INTRIGUE trial was
conducted and led. It was a phase three trial that compared
repretinib to sunitinib, using the standard way of
using it,
and looked at outcomes. The answer was repretinib was no
better than sunitinib. However, there was
additional data that was evaluated looking specifically at
those secondary mutations. And using ctDNA data
for patients who had AP secondary mutations, those 13, 14,
we saw what we expected to some extent.
Sunitinib did better than repretinib in terms of progression-free
survival. On the other hand, for the AL mutations, or those involving
17, 18, repretinib was far superior.
And so this led to the INSIGHT trial, which specifically
compared these in that AL secondary mutation
cohort, and that study has completed accrual, and we await those results.
Bevaclastinib,
first known as PLX9486, was studied as a single agent
as well as in combination with sunitinib, really
trying to key in on controlling all types of secondary mutations in
GIST. And you can see there was some activity with a
single agent, but the combination
showed a progression-free survival of a year in patients who were heavily
treated in this phase 1b trial. And looking at these
swimmer plots, you can see that some of these were true responses, more than
30% decrease, and quite long-lasting, which led to the
phase three PEAK trial, which randomized patients to this
combination. And you'll see the sunitinib dose here that was the comparator
was a slightly different dose than the FDA-approved regimen.
We've known for a long time that sunitinib given daily at a slightly lower dose is
very tolerable and effective, and to compare it in
a sort of maybe fair way to bevacizumab with this combination, that
was the dose chosen. We don't have the published data, but
a press release in November showed that this combination
was highly effective with a PFS of 16 and a
half months compared to 9.2 months with a very high
hazard ratio and
level of significance. And so very exciting data, and we look
forward to understanding more about it at ASCO.
I wanted to touch base briefly on avapritinib because while the drug has been very
effective, we have started to see resistance,
and as you might have expected, the resistance is
happening in the ATP binding pocket of
PDGFR alpha. And in work done in Sebastian Bauer's
lab in Germany, Ines and Therre have been looking at what
type of activity or drugs could we use against this, and really none of our
standard drugs really have a lot of activity, and so we're in search for
novel agents to treat this.
And those secondary mutations that are in
PDGFR alpha are sort of an example of what we're seeing in the evolution of
resistance. Typically, we start with a
tumor with one mutation. Over time, we'll get secondary resistance
mechanisms, secondary resistance mutations.
Oftentimes, we have a mixed population, but more recently, we've come to
identify that we can see tertiary, what are termed APPLE
mutations. And so in one
cell, on one chromosome, one gene,
in GIST you will see all three of these mutations.
So
currently, these are very challenging because again, looking at a broad
spectrum of agents, even some of the new ones being tested, very
limited activity when it comes to trying to control these APPLE
mutations, and really in the PDGFR
alpha context, no
activity. And so
we strategize by trying to use
alternative ways. Sometimes we try recycling to think maybe there's a population
of
cells that has grown that is sensitive to one agent.
We'll try using local modalities, but really clinical trials are the way to go,
particularly for looking at studies that may be using alternative types
of ways of attacking KIT or PDGFR alpha.
There have been studies looking at antibody drug conjugates,
also combinations using
drugs with alternative mechanisms,
either
work together with KIT or alternatively trying to affect
additional pathways in the cell. So in
conclusion, most GISTs are driven by kinase mutations.
Testing for the prime mutation is really important for developing
or choosing the right first choice.
Management in the second-line setting appears to be improved by treatments with
tyrosine kinases with broader coverage of both AP and AL
mutations. AndAs we continue to
look, KIT and PDGFR alpha continue to appear to be the main drivers in
these tumors, even with complex resistance mutations.
So as we move forward, I think as a field, we're thinking about using
these broad-spectrum agents earlier on to try and prevent
the development of these secondary and tertiary mutations.
We still are thinking about how can we target KIT and PDGFR alpha
in different ways besides just attacking the kinase.
We certainly need to continue to study the biology of these
mutations to understand what they're doing to cellular processes, and are
there other cellular processes that we can target;
and looking for what resistance is showing us in these
patients so that we can develop the next line of therapy.
Thank you, and I'd be happy to take any questions.
Great work. Do you think these triple mutants are a selective
pressure from these drugs, or do you think it may be an intrinsic property where
you are selecting for them and then they eventually rise?
So that's a great question, one that's debated oftentimes.
Clearly, they're emerging under selective pressure.
Mike Heinick, who's in the audience, has spent a lot of time trying to model these
in the lab and can, with mutagenesis, get them to appear in cell
models.
So I don't know.
We think they come from selective pressure, but whether there's a role
or
there being additional mutations
developing. I don't know, Mike, if you want to comment, because you are really more
of an expert on this than I am.
Well, I would say it's true. We don't really know.
We actually think that in some cases, the triple mutations,
the
cell has to make a selective trade-off because the kinase is less
fit than if it didn't have these mutations like T670I in the
ATP binding pocket, the gatekeeper, that in many
kinases like Abl and also in KIT, we think it makes it less
robust,
but it gains by being resistant to the drug.
So we think it's selection, but it's a little
not optimal from the standpoint. GIST, we
think, are very...
It's the amount of signaling. So too much is bad,
too little is bad, and so it's like the Goldilocks.
And so it's constantly counter-regulating with phosphatases and stuff to get
to the same point. And so apparently, it can take less
kinase to be drug resistant, but it has to do some
kind of adaptive things.
But I would imagine, and I think Sebastian's done some of these
things, where if you grow them competitively in the absence
of a drug, like the T670I guys, all those clones
just drop out because they're less fit.
We also,
because we can't, with sequencing, actually figure this out because they're too
far apart,
and most of our models are triple and cis, but could
you be in trans with the
AP on one
part of the protein and AL on the other, and so how would that
model out, too? So there's a lot we don't know.
Thank you so much.
I guess as long as I'm standing up, I'll invite you to speculate.
So, we always want to bring our better drugs earlier, which is
what we're doing, but how much do you think that we're losing down
the line by using our better drugs first or second?
Because right now we have four lines, but will we only have two
in the future?
Yeah. No, it's a great question because I think the trade-off or
what we're betting is that by doing it early, we're going to suppress it
so it doesn't show up. But I think
all too often cancer cells just are smart and
figure out another way, and so that we'll see alternative resistance mechanisms.
And so,
the
data's going to show us is from what we've seen so far, is it
better to control and not have the resistance develop
for three years instead of sequencing through drugs where you might have done it
for three years, or are we gaining time by doing this, by
suppressing it? Certainly, we have some suggestion
by looking at the role of surgery in patients who've developed progressive
disease. We think we can set their
clock back by removing tumor that has resistance.
And so are we doing the same thing by using our drugs
instead of doing surgery?
So,
I do worry about what our resistance is going to look like because right now our
triple mutants are really a challenge in terms of trying to take care of.
And so,
there's a lot of work going on in looking at new and different ways of targeting,
and I think
time will tell.
So one thing that's always struck me about GIST is,
I remember in the early days, when George was pushing
imatinib, I remember we were all celebrating and saying, "Well, we will no
longer need surgeons." I remember it was a classic comment from him.
And what we discovered was that
GIST cells didn't die.
The big disappointment was we could control them, but they wouldn't die.
And so I don't know if you want to speculate or have any thoughts now on what
have really become
what we used to call quiescent cells, now more
persister cells in GIST and what people are doing in that area.
Because, I think that if you could get
a drug that would kill the tumor initially, then we
wouldn't be having all these problems with resistance.
And that always seemed a really key problem and a key question to me.
Yeah. No, you're absolutely right.
There's a subset of cells that become just
persistent and don't go away. We clearly see significant tumor
shrinkage. Some cells do die, but just not all of them.
So I think the question is figuring out what
those cells are doing and how you can specifically target them.
Because
when we think about chemotherapy or other drugs that target cells,
oftentimes we're thinking about ways that these cells need to be in some way
growing or dividing so
we can affect them and have the process happen for them to
die. So surgery, in one way, is a great way of
removing, if you have bulk tumor left or
patients had a good response and then they have residual disease that's not
changing or shrinking, that surgery is oftentimes done
now,
and many patients, I think, have their life extended by being able
to undergo surgery if they can because you're probably removing some persistent
cells. Although there are probably some cells that we're not seeing because they're
micrometastatic, and we haven't detected them, and so at some time,
they will start growing again. It's sort of figuring out what is that switch and
how does it turn on, or if we could figure out how to
keep it off, turned on, the persistence phenotype
maintained, that would be okay, too, because they would never start growing and
dividing.
Okay.
Thanks.
Great.
Miguel, you want to close out the session?